hello my name is 肇社長
アヤム
8 java にー2
タワーそう
今日
愛を d 遠く犬 riche
そうとぅんです eyes
ゆうあいすくりるって空
パン刑事リースデリー車
だと赤と黒でちょっと怖い感じがする
スイス消費5 only
シェル
only 次戦商品
is is only
すっ
ローソンと先行販売アフターどっち後いろんなお店で売られるアイスになること
でしょう
o 君
た
大
ジャズベリー
アイス
黒い藍住なることでしょう
早速 eat eat なぁ
ああ
ここはブラックココアのお腹のカバーで
グリームしだてのミルクアイスカフェモカソースキャラメルチョココーティングの4
種類のジャンル言えずミックス
インキ your
そう目がかゆいけどそんなことは気にしないなちょっと増え続けました
実は僕英語できます
レイテ州というのはまあ
意味的には深さとか海の底までの深さとのことでぷつって言うんですよね
深さとかそういう中
ふかふか司ということですっていうね the 分
深みのあるアイスクリームにしたかったんでしょうかね
ローソンの今先行発売してるらしくてこれから出回る
新しい会津らしいですね
x-メンデブス
oh no 前ブラインドタッチの脳のアイキャント see イヤー
ローンではで伏せ本当に美味しいんだよ
ぜひ買ってみてください
hey じゃぬ
おまっ